I've drawn this crate small and there's
been quite a lot of controversy about
there's an and people don't realize that
so if I ask you the question how many of
these cookies and many thought parties
do you think they'd be on a saying one
side on one on one page once I I'm gonna
think you've simplified that you've got
three or four so maybe six or seven
every one of those gives you a tiny
amount of money so and something quite a
lot controversy from a from
dictionary.com as a website which n a
Wall Street Journal article just said
pointed out had two hundred of these two
hundred two hundred third party cookies
added okay so these sites are often
principally about providing you
information to allow their advertisement
industry to capture your preferences and
cut and deliver information to you the
advertising agencies quite rightly would
say this is a bit target in the
advertising so that you can actually
enhance their advertising experience as
well but the the difficult it comes from
the complex they're behind the scenes so
what's happening with those cookies and
the knowledge of those cookies and who's
selling those cookies to each other in
order to do this so part of that is
understanding not just you know these
are times are you but you might be
getting additional things targeted to
you that you may not one
intercept than these and understand and
these and understand and what people
know about you becomes important and
also how those things may impact your
life long-term I mean that's a an issue
about all other digital information how
it may get used and how it may get used
in different sorts of ways so the main
revenue stream for these advertisers
often what's called click-through so
that so basically the people who put the
advert out and P pertains people click
at it now this has been a problematic in
itself so there's been debates about
clicked what's called click-through
froid people are actually clicking
through to and run up a bill in a
competitor okay so there are ways in
which you can try and stop that being
done automatically by a machine and
making sure is by a human but really
what the advertisers won and need is
much more information
this so they would be interested for
example and how long you look at an
advert and did be interested in the
gender and age group indeed profiles of
the people that have responded times and
not responding talents they'd be
interested and they'd be interested also
and on the sequence part of reading a
page and then looking at an ad van all
of these are really useful information
to them and so part of the controversy
here is given they're interested in
trying to find it more and more about
this there's obviously a motivation
there to understand us and are we
comfortable with that are we just as
comfortable with understanding that at
the lateness to research example this
may kind of explain research example so
those are a field of computing called
effective computing and what that's been
done in a number of places and most
notably at MIT Media Lab have looked at
the ways in which you could use a webcam
to actually just look at the face of
somebody looking at a screen and then
decide whether they were happy or
whether they were sad so they've
developed the system where you can
actually download look at a video and do
the equivalent of what used to have to
be done manually by focus groups by
seeing the BET's of a video that may
yell happy me so so they've been serving
video ads to people and watching their
reactions on the on the screen so as
these adverts get more sophisticated
more and more of that understanding each
other what an understanding what the
reactions are has to happen and so I
think the big question is how much do we
want that to happen and how aware do we
need to be that that's happening you
could be very sensationalist about this
those of you who've ever read and have
ever read 1984 will remember the part of
this involved in every TV having a
camera okay if you go ahead and buy a TV
now you'll notice most of them have
cameras and most of them have escaped so
we are actually at a society now where
every TV has a camera who controls it
who does it who watches it and the seems
true of all these things for the the
discussion and
B has to be about what has been captured
and how's it been shared